was that what what was that um then you
know obviously you almost lost your life
it was very public and think about that
I
did
and you know I'm admitting to you you
know doing drugs you know in the hood
that you would never do right
I ain't do drugs that night though
really growing up
so
what was was it were you a Viagra or
some [ __ ] I mean yeah I was I was going
to have sex that night you know since I
Was preparing that night because you had
um Cardiac Arrest right I had everything
yeah I was under I had
12 strokes and six heart attacks
Jesus and what so what what brought that
on
the drugs that they slipped me I guess
oh they slipped you some [ __ ] yeah and
as a you know as a drug addict I was
like I wish you would have told me what
it was because that had to be some good
[ __ ] to lay me down for three days right
I woke up I couldn't walk or talk or
nothing I remember dude it was scary
yeah I think the scariest part for me
was not being able to talk
that's got to be frustrating you can't
communicate
you know that's got to be crazy
that is extremely humbling I'm just
thinking about I'm two-time NBA champion
Lamar Odom
feel me I'm laying in Cedar sign now I
can't even hold my bowels my G yeah
nurses coming to change me every
three or four hours or something like
that
man do you feel like that it sometimes
because you know I grew up in a family
with a lot of drug addicts uh very close
to me and I almost feel like
you almost have to hit a certain Rock
Bottom before
you kind of get
woken up a bit or really truly evaluate
your [ __ ] do you feel like that that was
kind of like a uh but for me it was
confusing because I'm like damn I ain't
even do drugs that night
but I think for me that ultimately was
wound up being like the you know
it's those gas station dick pills man
the way that yeah
I think that I think that was the one
the [ __ ] that made me like yo you know
you could lose your life I got too much
to live for yeah you can lose your life
just live in a certain way man well I
got kids man my daughter's 24. that's
crazy my son 21. you got some grown-ass
children man
it's wild bro you do man you do